Vice President Mike Pence rejects a
report that he's in the early stages of
a shadow campaign for president in case
President Trump does not run for
re-election the president is spending
the next two weeks at his Golf Club in
New Jersey he tweeted this is not a
vacation meetings and calls major
Garrett is in Bridgewater New Jersey
near the Trump International Golf Club
major good morning good morning
president Trump's vacation of course
provides no respite from the threat of
North Korea or international efforts
which the president has monitored here
at the United Nations and elsewhere to
deter North Korea's pursuit of nuclear
weapons but even though the president's
vacation has just begun the disciplining
influence of his new chief of staff
former with that is to say retired
Marine general John Kelly is clearly
evident Kelley has put in place a
process now to pre-screen the
president's Twitter messages and the
number meaning fewer of them and tighter
focus this weekend is an example of
Kelly's disciplining effect on the
president social media habits in
Washington inside the White House Kelly
has also taken up position just outside
the Oval Office screening those who want
to see the president to find out what
their agenda is and how much time they
want to spend with the president also
Kelly has decided to put himself along
with the President on all policy related
phone calls that's something you'll have
a chance to do throughout the
president's vacation because as you
mentioned Blatt taking phone calls and
meetings while here in New Jersey is one
of the few details the White House has
released about president Trump's
intentions